which of the world's most cited papers
nature asked Thompson Reuters for the
top 100 from its web of science database
which goes back more than a century if
you printed out the first page of every
item in this index the stack of paper
would almost reach to the top of Mount
Kilimanjaro more than half has been
cited only once or not at all
only the top metre and a half of the
mountain has more than 1,000 citations
among these what's an encrypt in the
structure of DNA but to reach the top
100 take something extra-special at
number one with over 300,000 citations
is a 1951 paper describing a way to
measure the amount of protein in a
solution similar biological methods
dominate the list along with papers on
software and statistics these most cited
papers aren't the most glamorous many of
them got to the top by a quirk of luck
or circumstance still scientists have
relied on these techniques to make more
famous advances explore some more of the
top 100 papers yourself at Nature calm /
top 100